يبحث الاتحاد الاوروبي خطه من ثلاثه
مسارات لدعم اوكرانيا في الحرب ضد روسيا
وتهدف الخطه الاوروبيه المقترحه الى
التعامل مع حاجات اوكرانيا من الذخائر عبر
مشروع شراء مدته سبع سنوات سيطلق قريبا
تقوده وكاله الدفاع الاوروبيه وذلك لتغطيه
حاجات الدول الاعضاء من ذخائر الاسلحه
الصغيره وحتى القذائف من عيار 155 ملي
مترا الخطه تنص على تقديم الذخائر الى
اوكرانيا بشكل فوري واعاده ملء مخزونات
الدول الاعضاء ورفع قدرات الانتاج داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي على المدى الطويل
كما تدعو الخطه الاوروبيه الى نقل فوري
الذخائر من المخزونات الحاليه او تلك التي
تم طلبها بالفعل لاوكرانيا
وتاتي هذه الخطه ردا على دعوات من دول
اعضاء لزياده انتاج الذخائر وسط تقديرات
بان روسيا تطلق في اليوم الواحد ما يوازي
ما تنتجه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي في شهر
ويقدر بنحو خمسين الف قذيفه في حين ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تستخدم ما يصل الى سبعه
الاف قذيفه يوميا وفق مسؤولين اوروبيين